eric adams is the mayor of new york city  eric adams is very upset because the  governor of texas greg abbott is bussing  illegal aliens to new york and dc and  all the other liberal cities eric adams  is furious about that he says it's  putting a severe strain on new york's  resources and eric adams says maybe he's  going to bust some new yorkers down to  texas to give governor abbott a piece of  their mind i already called all of my  friends in  texas  and told them  how to cast their vote and  i am deeply contemplating taking a bus  load of new yorkers uh to go to texas  and do some good old-fashioned door  knocking uh because we  we have to for the good of america we  have to get him out of office why you  got to get him out of office the good of  america it's a sanctuary city the whole  premise is you want the illegal aliens  to come